Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a neuf ans,
après une longue période d’interrogation,
de questionnement,
j’ai eu le courage d’affronter mes peurs,
de me confronter au réel
et d’assumer qui j’étais.
Je sentais bien que j’étais différent,
que je ne ressemblais pas complètement
aux garçons qui m’entouraient.
Mais paralysé par la peur,
je gardais au fond de moi
ce que je ressentais vraiment.
Et puis, un jour, je me suis lancé,
je me suis dit : « Maxime, vas-y ! »
Je me rappelle très bien,
c’était un dimanche midi,
un repas de famille.
J'ai regardé mon père, ma mère.
J’ai pris une grande inspiration
et je l’ai dit, enfin.
« Papa, maman,
je suis
féministe. »
Alors, je sais, ça peut étonner,
mais en 2012, ce n’était pas si fréquent
pour un homme de se dire féministe.
Alors qu’aujourd’hui, en 2021,
le monde a tellement changé.
C’est simple, je ne peux plus
aller en soirée
sans rencontrer des dizaines de garçons
qui viennent me dire :
« Mais moi aussi, je suis féministe. »
Quand je dîne avec mes copines,
elles me disent toutes :
« La charge mentale à la maison,
mais c’est terminé.
Maintenant, les tâches matérielles,
on est sur du 50/50. »
J’allume la télé, pas un match de foot
sans voir une femme arbitre siffler
Mbappé et Neymar.
Et surtout en 2021,
autant de femmes que d’hommes
à la tête des entreprises et des États.
C’est le moment de la soirée
où vous vous dites :
« Soit le mec est passé complètement
à côté de son sujet,
soit il essaie de faire un effet de style
pour interpeller l’auditoire. »
Voilà, option deux.
Mesdames, messieurs surtout,
j’ai envie qu’on se parle
franchement ce soir.
Sommes-nous collectivement
à la hauteur de ce mouvement
qu’on est en train de vivre ?
De cette vague post-MeToo,
de cette révolution des esprits ?
En tant qu’hommes,
sommes-nous conscients
de notre position de privilégiés ?
Oui, de privilégiés.
Bien sûr, dans la vie,
nous ne partons pas tous sur
la même ligne de départ, c’est vrai.
Mais au global, les femmes
partent encore de plus loin.
Je ne me suis jamais fait
siffler dans le métro,
quelle que soit l’heure,
quelle que soit la station.
Je n’ai jamais fait semblant de téléphoner
pour éviter qu’on m’importune.
Je ne me suis jamais dit en prenant
un poste dans une entreprise :
« Bizarre, j’ai l’impression que
la femme à côté gagne plus que moi
alors qu’on est arrivé
en même temps. »
Et surtout, je n’ai jamais eu peur
d’annoncer à mon employeur
mon futur congé paternité et que
j’allais m’arrêter quelques mois.
Pour toutes ces raisons
et pour bien d’autres encore,
oui, je suis privilégié
et c’est bien de le dire,
juste d’en être conscient,
de le reconnaître tout simplement.
Alors, une fois qu’on a dit ça,
qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Déjà, répondre à cette question :
« Suis-je légitime en tant qu’homme
pour dénoncer des injustices ? »
Mais la réponse est oui, évidemment.
Mais il suffit de le faire
à sa place, à ma place,
sans prendre celle d’une femme.
En assumant ma position d’homme,
conscient de ses privilèges.
La deuxième question que
je me suis longtemps posée,
c’est comment faire pour
contribuer à cette égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes ?
Comment apporter ma pierre à l’édifice ?
Et là, c’est très simple,
il faut passer aux actes.
J’ai la conviction qu’en 2021,
il n’est plus possible de se dire
féministe, progressiste, pro-égalité
sans transformer notre pensée, nos paroles
par un changement effectif
de nos comportements.
Pas besoin d’être membre d’une association
ou d’aller dans des manifs,
si ce n'est pas dans votre ADN.
Chaque personne présente dans cette salle
a le pouvoir de changer des choses.
Participer à ce chemin vers l’égalité,
c’est déjà dénoncer les injustices
dans la sphère publique autour de soi.
Il faut s’élever contre chaque acte
de violence sexiste et sexuelle,
même si ça nous coûte,
même si c’est compliqué.
Le pire sera toujours de ne rien faire.
On s’est tous retrouvés une fois
face à ce collègue de bureau
qui commente la tenue de la stagiaire
une fois qu’elle est sortie de la pièce.
Ça nous est déjà arrivé.
Alors,
vous pourriez y aller
frontalement et lui dire :
« Hé, mais Ludo, t’es vraiment qu’un
gros beauf et en plus, t’es un peu con. »
mais quelque chose me dit
que ça ne marchera pas vraiment.
Et si la prochaine fois, vous lui disiez :
« Mais Ludo, tu aimerais
qu’on parle de ta fille comme ça ? »
Tout de suite, c'est différent.
Participer à l’égalité,
c’est aussi regarder ce qui
se passe chez soi à la maison.
Qu’est-ce qui, dans ma vie personnelle,
peut être amélioré, modifié ?
Peut-être même remplacé ?
Une répartition des tâches domestiques
peut-être un peu inégalitaire.
Ça vous dit quelque chose ?
Est-ce que descendre les poubelles
une fois par semaine équivaut
à passer la serpillière et récurer
les toilettes, un jour sur deux ?
Pas sûr.
Si j’accompagne mon bébé à la crèche,
c’est la même chose d’aller le chercher
tous les soirs et de faire
aussi les devoirs de l’aîné
tout en pensant aux repas
et aux activités sportives du plus grand ?
Pas sûr non plus.
Pour moi, il y a trois
lieux d’intervention
pour changer les choses concrètement.
Trois lieux d'intervention prioritaires.
Le premier, on vient d’en parler,
c’est l’éducation.
Concernant la vie à la maison,
on vient de le dire,
du chemin reste à faire.
Pourtant, parents, futurs parents,
grands-parents,
vous êtes les premiers
rôles modèles de vos enfants.
Chacun de vos comportements
est épié, analysé, imité
par des enfants qui, des années
plus tard, reproduiront vos gestes.
Bien sûr, chaque couple
fait comme il veut.
Personne n’est là
et surtout pas moi
pour décider de ce qui
se passe dans les foyers.
Mais soyons conscients d'une chose.
Si nous ne changeons pas
nos comportements,
quelle image renvoie-t-on
aux générations futures ?
Et si nous ne bousculions pas
collectivement nos habitudes ?
Je serai là encore des années plus tard
à vous parler de ce sujet.
Quant à l’école, contrairement à
ce que vous avez déjà dû entendre,
l’éducation à l’égalité
est une obligation.
Ce n'est pas une option,
ce n'est pas un débat.
Lorsque j’étais conseiller
au ministère des Droits des femmes,
on avait lancé un module qui s’appelait
les « ABCD de l’égalité »
pour faire l’égalité, pour apprendre
aux enfants l’égalité et le respect.
Et une énorme polémique
avait enflé sur le sujet :
« Ah, mais vous êtes en train
d’installer la théorie du genre. »
Je ne sais pas ce qu’est
la théorie du genre ;
si vous avez la définition,
appelez-moi, ça m’intéresse.
La vérité, c’est que
cette théorie n’existe pas,
l’égalité est prévue
par le Code de l’Éducation.
Tout comme les maths,
le français ou les SVT.
Libre à vous de regarder ce qui se passe
dans les écoles de vos enfants
et de comprendre
comment on traite de ce sujet.
Le deuxième champ d'intervention,
c'est la culture.
La culture est une arme redoutable
pour bousculer nos représentations,
pour nous rappeler que la vie,
la vraie vie, c’est la parité.
Et pourtant, espace de liberté,
la culture nous enferme
encore dans des carcans.
Combien d’héroïnes au cinéma ?
Combien de rappeuses,
combien de cheffes d’orchestre ?
Combien de personnages féminins
dans les jeux vidéo ?
Beyoncé a probablement davantage contribué
à la diffusion des idées féministes,
même si elle ne fait pas l’unanimité,
que des milliers d’articles sur le sujet.
Alors, je ne suis pas Beyoncé - scoop -
mais en tant que producteur,
j’essaie de contribuer
à cette nouvelle image du féminisme,
plus inclusive,
plus positive, ouverte.
Souvenez-vous d’une chose
en sortant de cette pièce :
les biens culturels que vous achetez
sont comme les yaourts que
nous choisissons au supermarché.
Soyez exigeantes, soyez exigeants,
faites le tri.
Votre portefeuille est aussi
une arme du changement.
Le troisième lieu d'intervention,
c'est l'entreprise.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’on y confronte nos points de vue,
on n’est pas toujours d’accord avec
le voisin, contrairement à la famille.
Dans mon travail, je propose
des contenus audiovisuels ludiques
pour sensibiliser les équipes à l’égalité.
Soyons clairs : le sexisme
est un sujet grave
mais la forme qu’on choisit pour le
combattre ne doit pas forcément l’être.
Bousculons les codes
et interrogeons-nous sans tabou,
si l’égalité femmes-hommes
progresse si lentement,
c’est peut-être que les outils
que nous utilisons pour la défendre
sont peut-être désuets.
Il est temps de montrer que la défense
de l'égalité n'a rien de méprisant,
d’arrogant ou d’excluant, non.
La fin des inégalités, c'est avant tout
la promesse d'une société plus apaisée
qui nous rendra plus épanouis,
plus heureux, plus fiers
de faire société ensemble.
Alors, c’est vrai, en tant qu’homme,
je pourrais faire un choix
tout à fait rationnel
et me dire :
« Quel intérêt j’ai à perdre
mes privilèges ? »
J’ai compris que je n’étais pas le seul
à espérer un autre modèle de société.
On était des milliers à ne pas se
reconnaître dans cette définition
de la masculinité.
Oui, comme tant d’autres,
je refuse ces injonctions virilistes
qu’on m’assène depuis que je suis né.
« Sois fort ! »
« Pleure pas !
montre  que c’est toi le chef. »
Ces stéréotypes, cette définition
grotesque du masculin,
ont essayé de m’enfermer dans
un rôle qui n’était pas le mien.
Ce chemin irrépressible vers l’égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes,
en réalité, ne m’enlève rien.
Il ne me retire aucun droit,
seulement des privilèges.
Contrairement à ce que
la société a peut-être essayé
de m’enseigner pendant des années,
j’ai aujourd’hui la conviction
que les privilèges
ne rendent pas plus heureux.
Alors, un jour, j’ai fait
mon coming out féministe.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je l’aime ce mot,
tout simplement.
J’ai compris à force d’en parler
que ce mot de féministe pouvait faire peur
à beaucoup d’hommes,
à beaucoup de femmes aussi,
parce qu’on le trouvait un peu
trop clivant, un peu trop militant.
Moi, je l’aime ce mot.
Je l’aime parce qu’il me
renvoie à une histoire
ou plutôt aux héroïnes de l’histoire.
A Olympe de Gouges,
à Simone Veil, à Malala.
Ce mot « féminisme » me rappelle aussi
que les droits des femmes sont fragiles,
qu’ils ne sont jamais acquis.
Les droits des femmes n’avancent pas,
ne stagnent pas, non,
ils reculent lorsqu’on ne prend pas
la peine de les défendre.
Y compris dans de très grandes
démocraties, on l’a vu encore récemment.
Cette marche en arrière, je vous le dis,
elle nous guette.
Alors, il n’est pas trop tard,
à une seule condition,
et j’espère vous l’avoir démontré ce soir,
cette condition, c’est agir.
Quelle société souhaitons-nous
pour demain ?
Le pari d’une nouvelle génération,
une nouvelle génération de petits garçons,
de petites filles soucieux d’évoluer
dans une société plus inclusive,
plus égalitaire.
Est-ce que ce n’est pas la promesse
la plus enthousiasmante qui soit ?
Alors,
on y va ?
Ça commence maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)